just one day away and the stakes could
not be higher over the weekend President
Joe Biden and former presidents Donald
Trump and Barack Obama campaigned in The
crucial Battleground States
two parties are delivering very
different closing messages with vastly
different Visions as they battle for
control of Congress it's a battle we've
got full team coverage across the
country today including Tony he's in
Florida where Trump's campaign push
could have big implications for 2024
we'll get to Tony in just a moment but
first we're going to go to Caitlin Huey
burn she's in Pennsylvania Caitlin good
morning to you it all seems to indicate
it's going to be a long night in
Pennsylvania
absolutely Gail good morning and good
morning to everyone if you needed any
more evidence that Pennsylvania is the
crucial State this term look at who is
here this weekend you had Barack Obama
Joe Biden and Donald Trump all trying to
use their presidential star power to
help turn out the vote with control of
the U.S Senate on the line
are you fired up yet
Pennsylvania packed with presidents this
Tuesday you must vote Republican the
outcome is going to shape our country
for decades to come the high-profile
visits show the Keystone State is key to
who controls the senate for the next two
years
democracy itself is on the ballot the
stakes are high
the race between Democrat John Federman
and Republican Amendment Oz is one of
the closest in the country that will
bring change to Washington so they treat
us the way we deserve and I'm going to
every one of you to go out and have your
plan get your friends get your families
all ready to vote
both fetterman and Oz spent Sunday in
the suburbs around Philadelphia
according key swing voters with closing
arguments made the challenge now is
turnout
be caught up with union members
supporting Democratic candidates
knocking on doors in minority
communities aiming to get voters to the
polls you're going door to door every
vote count yes every vote does count so
we know that it's very important for
every single vote
and across town Democratic volunteers
Belinda Birnbaum and Jessica Clemens
spent their Sunday giving rides to
voters like Toya Perkins who was
notified she had not signed her mail-in
ballot they call me to come down here to
make sure that my vote counts and that's
exactly what I did every single person
deserves to have their vote counted and
we're going to do everything we can to
make sure that happens
now election experts and election
officials here can't start opening up
ballots until election day those mail-in
ballots so it may be a while before we
get results here in Pennsylvania and
Nate election experts are already
bracing for legal challenges with this
year's result
Caitlin thank you